it is a growing problem across the
valley abandoned homes and businesses
filled with squatters now the city of
las vegas wants to do something about
this issue christian kosovos has studied
this story joining us live in studio
with exactly how bad is this problem
christian well brian according to the
city there are about 200 properties that
are flagged as nuisance now these are
abandoned homes or businesses where the
owners have not taken care of the
property and now the city is taking
action
there was couches mattress there was a
homeless guy sleeping on one of the
mattress right here steve sanson says
this abandoned home on monticello drive
is giving his neighborhood a black eye
the trash was blue and spurring over to
the other house and and was causing a
nuisance over there and plus it was um
roach infested according to councilman
brian knutson it's not the only one
about 200 properties around the inner
corridor of las vegas are causing
similar problems after several failed
attempts to reach those landlords the
city is taking action the city wants to
take decisive action and move very
quickly to board up the property in some
cases tear down the property so that we
can keep neighborhoods looking clean we
spotted this woman entering the
abandoned home on tuesday morning after
the city tells 8 news now the property
should be vacant neighbors share these
images of trash around the home and even
a dog was left unattended issues this
neighbor wants fixed fast we want to
keep everything clean and and welcoming
and and
that home is not clean nor welcoming
and nobody wants to drive by there
because if you drive by there you think
that the whole neighborhood is like that
well the city council will address this
issue tomorrow and if approved they will
either demolish or fence off these
vacant properties of course we will keep
an eye on this vote christian casadas 8
news now